[Music]
welcome to another gains to know by
heart class to your Thursday night at
the st. Louis chess club
this is Grandmaster Christian Karina and
I will be presenting your game of
Vladimir Kramnik a guy that's still
active even though this game has been
played in 1992 and he was one of the
strongest players back then he's still
one of the strongest strongest players
right now and he almost qualified to the
candidates though he did to Americans
did Wesley so and Fabiano corona and the
game I'm going to present to you is a
game between him and a guy named the
Putin from Armenia very strong
grandmaster let's see this is as we will
see is a demolition very very quick
demolition d 4e 6 c4 Knight f6 Knight f3
obviously if we play nice e3 we're
allowing what we're allowing the name
zone so even in 1992 night f3 was the
fashion right now night a lot of people
play night night where 3 a lot of people
that enjoy more or less strategical
concepts rather than forced moves if you
play Knight c3 Bishop before Black is
considered to equalize in most
theoretical lines and if you want to
play some very aggressive approach with
f3 then you're going to have to know a
lot of theory and I remember a game
between if I remember correctly Wesley
so as white and Aronian as back or
Aronian as well no huronian as wider
mostly saw as black one of them lost
really bad as as white I think c5 d5 we
had this type of strange benoni
structure with the bishop on b4 but the
King never Castle
with a white king never Castle then
slowly slowly black species got out he
played some like this six he exchanged
and the bishop car of the night got out
might went to e5 and the black the White
King just got checkmated very very
quickly so just demolition you have to
be very careful if you choose to play
this type of Lights night of three is
much more tame approach yeah black
doesn't have the options of opening up
opening up the position such like in
that variation be five nights III now
Bishop before is a completely different
story I think it's called the Rogozin
and now we're going to play up we have a
few options as why we can play Bishop g5
which is the main line and it is what I
play and after age six once again we
have two options we can go Bishop h4 or
Bishop takes f6 which is a bit more
popular Bishop takes f6 Queen takes f6
and now we can force this night to go to
c6 in front of the pawn on c7 which we
know in the Queens gambit declined is
not necessarily a good thing
so we can go queen a4 knight c6 III and
okay we put replaced blacks we forced
black's pawn blacks piece on a bad
square but what does black have in
return what did he get in return
he got the bishop are exactly he got the
bishop er and okay I mean white is
considered to be slightly better I think
for your reference I think there is a
recent game from the Sinquefield Cup if
I'm not mistaken Aronian versus Wesley
so in which are only unemployed quite a
nice nice plan on the kingside and he
managed to break through and win he also
had a very very deep preparation so I
definitely suggest you guys go and and
analyze that one it's typical to
destroyed type of structures but he
played Bishop e7 which is quite safe
Bishop to f4 now Bishop to f4 or Bishop
g5 Bishop g5 is the other main line and
after Castle III hh6 Bishop here White
has a black I think b6 is the main line
he can also play Knight be d7 there's a
few ways in which you can play again
white is considered slightly slightly
better but generally black manages to
equalize out of the opening so he played
Bishop to f4 Castle I like Bishop a4 by
the way this is a the move that I'm
playing as well it's a bit more flexible
it's a bit more novel it has more hidden
I guess ideas and concepts and it
doesn't allow any forced variations
no no no Jabbar please b3 I'd move one
number one generally one b3 which is a
quite an interesting interesting move I
have been analyzing it a little bit
recently and there is some poise into
one b3 yeah he plays some very strange
stuff generally no this is this is still
quite topical quite a topical line c6
nowadays a c5 is is encountered at at
high level as well as 97 night to d7 and
a lot of people played this move c5
blocking the position on this side and
after a 6h three make space for my
bishop to wait to go to h2 whenever he's
going to be attacked by the knight on
age five I think the variation goes
something like this
you should pay six we exchanged the
bishops Quincey eight or Queenie eight
and I don't remember exactly a position
is considered to be very very slightly
better for white
it's very blocked I'm going to open up
the as black I'm going to open up the DA
file I'm going to take on b4 then I'm
going to close the position and then
you're going to have two white as white
you're going to have to find a way to
break through on the King side that's
where we have the advantage that's your
only chance generally black people
manage to black black players manage to
equalize and most games end up in a draw
nevertheless black will suffer in this
type of positions in this type of
structures c6 was played Queen c2 97 h3
what is white not doing and we were
discussing that in the previous class as
well
exactly
white is trying to find as many useful
moves as he can before he plays the move
Bishop to e2 Bishop to e2 or Bishop d3
because he's waiting for black to take
on c4 and I want to take on C forth in
one move
yeah if you would play Bishop e2 I would
as black I will simply take on c4 and
then at least I would whenever you take
back on c4 I will gain one tempo so
white is trying to find as many useful
moves as he can he's going to play h3
sometimes root d1 then even a3 and at
some point one of the players is going
to run out of moves
depending on the specific variation
let's see hmm which one take the pawn
with with the Ponyo me that's that's an
interesting idea
after h3 or before h3 does have an idea
because whenever you go Knight h5
sometimes I'm going to withdraw my
Bishop on h2 right if you go b3 here I
think I can go Knight h5
the problem with b-tree your bishop is
out and you don't have any cover on dark
squares
whenever you play b3 you would like to
have the bishop on b2 to go to be to to
protect the dark squares unfortunately
with the bishop on f4 I'm probably going
to be able to take advantage of that
absence play move such as Queen a5 this
Bishop maybe comes to b4 and your Bishop
on f4 is not really doing much yeah he's
a bit out of the game so you have to be
careful with b3 generally you you would
like to put your pawn on a3 so that you
limit the bishop you're kind of playing
for for limiting your opponent's pieces
here a six rook d1 so he is still
waiting with that move Bishop e2 h6 and
black is doing the same thing he's not
taking on c4 neither of them is is doing
that a3 as you can see everybody's
waiting it's it's like a chicken game
game of chicken
d take C for finally you have to make it
yeah
or you can play something like rookie a
but rookie 8 is already I don't know it
doesn't seem like it's a useful move to
be honest it does help your cause a
little bit because it opens up that F 8
squared for potentially the bishop to
return closer the king or the knight to
maneuver v odd f8 so it might be a
useful move
I think the tech C for is definitely not
a good one because after after Bishop
takes c4 now white should enjoy quite
quite a nice advantage let's see what he
played 95
and what to do now
what to do now
take with the night-night xt5 but once
again who has space advantage
white has space advantage
you I mean even if you do want if even
if you are going straight pieces at
least don't do it voluntarily you know
at least let him loose another move yeah
that's an option
Bishop to g3 is an option absolutely but
the after Knight c3 Queen takes c3 okay
why it still enjoys a nice advantage
nevertheless blacks should be able to
somehow hold maybe play something like
b5 the bishop goes somewhere maybe even
and then we should be 7 Queen b6 the
same plan yeah c5 if we can get c5 as
soon as possible open up the Bishop on
b7 and if I manage to do that then my
pieces are going to be perfectly
coordinated and I'm not going to have
any issues Brooksie
we have to be careful a little bit how
many moves were going to give white I
would rather keep the rukon a8 because
if white tries to play something like b4
to stop me completely from playing the
move c5 then I can have at least ideas
with a5 and breaking up the position on
that side that's why I would like to
keep the rock on it at least for the
moment of course at some point the rook
once the the C file opens up the rock on
C it is going to be a perfect piece but
for the moment I think the roots should
stay on it correct always try to you
always have options yeah try to try try
to think in terms of flexibility for the
future as well yeah see what move is
going to preserve that that cooperation
of your pieces and which move is going
to give you more options in the future
as you as you mesh so
Bishop g3 is one any other candidate
it's very obvious guys castle exactly do
we actually need to lose tempo by by by
removing the Bishop from f4 or can we
just continue with with our development
and I'll let him take on f4 that's what
he did he played castle he didn't lose a
single tempo and I think this is the
right decision he is better developed
and this is a very typical structure
actually whenever we allow our opponent
take on f4 I've played it a few times as
white I generally like to play this as
white despite blacks blacks advantages
that he has the bishop air yeah the
problem is he's very restrictive his
bishop era is extreme he 5 is a huge
square if I was definitely a huge square
and I'm going to try to place my pawns
most of the times this point on g3 to
defend the f4 because he's most probably
going to try to attack it with Queen c7
this point on h4 most of the times again
depending on how we're going to how
we're going to deal with the position
whether we're going to try to attack
blacks King immediately or whether we're
going to adopt more of a strategic
approach to just slowly slowly build our
position we will see in just second
which one Cromley chose but if I would
be to go for the strategic approach I'll
put my my pawns on the dark squares to
limit this Bishop to limit the dark
square Bishop then I'll put my knight in
the center rooks on the central files
and then I'm just going to maneuver
around it yeah we will see I don't want
to give too much away because I'm going
to ask you at some point for the plan
and you guys are going to have to find
it let's see how it continued Queen c7
95 chromic is not losing and it
gee three would be a loss of tempo so
that's that's why I meant when I said he
chose the dynamic approach you chose to
go for the King immediately as we will
see Knight to f6 what to do now so this
is the critical moment guys I want you
to think like kramnik create a plan
powerful grammar improve your pieces
that can be improved and also we don't
have the same support in the center
that's one of the characteristics of the
position the fact that that night only
five is so powerful and it's supported
by two points two points if it would be
supported only by one point I could
immediately start attacking it with
Bishop d6 undermined his position and so
on with two points he's just you would
have to play f6 to take it away but the
f6 would give me so many squares you
know a different plan and that's this
other type of positions that if you
analyze and if you try to understand the
plans you're going to earn basically a
new set of patterns that you're going to
recognize in your games and you're going
to know where the pieces are going to go
so these are the type of middle games
that you cannot just skim through and
not try to understand when you're
analyzing when you're analyzing a game
you have to ask yourself why why why did
he do that will I remember next time
when I will have this structure
generally patterns you're going to
remember because of the structure
some candidates guys rock everyone is is
very natural move absolutely but one of
one of kremlings trademark in in in this
game is that he what most of most of his
games actually is that he's not losing
time if he doesn't have to play look
everyone rock everyone is a move that we
can make for the next 20 moves no yeah
he's not gonna stop work everyone I
don't like before conceptually is it's
good but the problem is after before
we're going to give him a target on
before he's going to go a five
immediately he's going to go a five and
then he's going to open up his pieces
yeah yeah if he manages to open up the
position obviously his bishop area is
going to become a strength right now the
the center is closed at least for the
moment
he's trying to keep it that way as much
as he can so that's why I said before
conceptually is good because you're
trying to keep the position closed
you're not allowing c5 but you're
allowing a five
any other piece that we could
potentially improve its position what
was the what was the plan of Queenie to
try to try to your your idea is good try
to create an attack on the king how are
you going to do that at some point sure
at some point but for the moment we can
actually we can actually create quite a
strong battery and by the way that's why
a3 is actually a useful move because
you're making space for for your Bishop
to go to be one it's a very useful move
why you're going to be one and then
you're going to play a move such as
maybe 90 for removing the knight on f6
right then we're going to get rid of the
knight maybe with 94 maybe with some
other idea as we will potentially see
Bishop a2 was played a very strong move
Bishop d7 Bishop b1
I mean the bishop on on that diagonal
right now is useful on the b1 h7
diagonal right now it's useful well
g6 doesn't really work because of 90 X
g6 I think that sacrifice is going to
work in a lot a lot of situations but
yeah I can always bring him back on this
diagonal right and maybe put some
pressure on this pawn chain nevertheless
for the moment it's much it's much more
proactive on b1 bishop EA which is
and in accuracy it allows white quite a
nice blow quite a nice tactical blow
nitrogen for is actually quite
interesting
the problem with Nyjah for the only
problem when I drew for is that he's
going to play what he has the forced
move otherwise yes checkmate it I think
Knight takes f6
then you take back on f6 and then queen
h7 so after Knight g4 there is only one
absolutely G 694 g6 and I don't really
like it that much even though you take
this pawn I go King g7 you go back and
then your f4 pawn is hanging I'm going
to call quintics h4 and okay
let's see what we exchanged we changed
upon on h6 black spot on h6 we managed
to block this important diagonal so the
Queen and the the Queen and the bishops
action on that diagonal is obsolete
there's doesn't really matter anymore
and then Brooke potentially comes to h8
now maybe black could create his own
threads on the bsh-2 diagonal so
basically we lost any potential for an
attack in my opinion yes this Bishop on
e8 that that was the whole point of this
maneuver Bishop d7 Bishop e8 because g6
works and it's it's supported and right
now actually g6 is a threat because you
no longer can take take and then take
with the Queen because the bishop on the
8th is protecting that
but the podium overlooked something
overlooked a very very nice aesthetic
blow by white the same problem g6
actually I might be able to even take
first take only for Queen takes e4 and
then g6
hmm f5 the same problem
f5 I'm going to take Queen takes a 5 and
then g6
that's my that basically that's my
threat g6 you just plug that that
diagonal d5
let's try to understand this move what's
the point his queen is hanging so after
both he takes d5 and Sita is d5
you play what move Knight takes d5
exactly and he cannot take back with the
knife because Queen h7 right so if you
take with the pawn I take now if you
take the Queen the problem is I have
this intermediary check Knight xe7 I
take your piece and you go back then I
take piece up yeah if you take with the
pawn your queen is hanging if you take
with the night the mate is hanging if
you move your queen anywhere else I'm
going to take on f6 and eliminate the
defender and then queen h7 is coming so
everything is forced the same happens if
you take with the e pawn exactly the
same thing so despite the fact that you
have so many defenders on this d5 pawn
d5 square the problem is most of your
defenders are immobile they're not
really defending that square so after
Knight takes d5 queen h7 is going to be
a huge huge problem white is just simply
winning so he's right now he's forced to
play the move rook to d8 what's the
first thing you should ask yourself
yes and you can realize very quickly
that you're not because I'm just taking
that's why he played through could d8
actually yeah to defend against that
pawn fork because okay let's say he's
moving something else let's say rook c8
yeah
now pawn fork the question was very good
is it working
I think it is in this situation because
after Bishop takes d6 now the
consequence of this move is that the
knight on f6 is no longer protected
twice
so now g6 after Knight g4 doesn't work
anymore you cannot plug this diagonal
there's no way you can stop Knight xf6
queen a queen h7 with a bishop on e7 you
would have the move g6 with the bishop
on d6 not really so now your King is
locked here by force I'm going to play
Knight xf6 queen of queen h7 checkmate I
don't think you can you can stop me from
doing that so actually that was a very
good question that's why he played rugby
a
another kind of automatic question
should be is he threatening anything
does he have any threats in the position
because black have any threats in this
position no he doesn't
despite the fact that he brought another
attacker on on on that d5 square is he
threatening to take on on d5 same thing
Knight takes d5 comes immediately so
let's just improve our position let's
just play a normal normal natural move
his his again he's not threatening
anything that's another that's an
important question you have to always
ask yourself rookie walk King h8 now
finally we're ready to create some
damage F takes c6 rook takes d12 Rock
take z1 f takes c6 continue continue
with the plan
were you thinking about rook d7
I think he has to take with the bishop
and despite the fact that you're getting
some some attack after night g6 King g8
and I take c7 but I think right now I
can maybe go out well don't don't don't
forget you you already sacrifice the
rook so if you take a look then I take
your knight and I want peace up the
night is still there yeah the night is
still there so no we have to continue
with our plan initial plan yes to remove
the defender yeah
to remove the defender of the light
squares around the King right the knight
on f6 again the night next to the castle
is extremely powerful it's an extremely
powerful defender if we can remove that
as an attacker we should definitely try
to doing that so Knight e4 is the move
of course g6 desperation basically there
is a not much else black could have done
and now he played a very nice move in my
opinion
because what he's doing he's not getting
attached to a certain path he's ready to
die divert his diversify his ideas and
shift his plan at the moment's notice
how to continue how to continue the
attack it's a good question
hahaha g4 is it's very aggressive
extremely extremely aggressive now I'm
not sure if that's a good thing
after g4 or if I go tonight here you
have to be very careful overextending
overextension is just a dangerous scene
so no not g4 it's it's tempting
come on guys we have a new a new
weakness the one on g6
if you take with the neither my go rook
takes f6 and I defend that pawn on g6
what's his best piece
besides the might which for what right
now he it it doesn't really do anything
anymore because there's some there's
something else defending that h7 square
and that is the pawn on g6 so besides
the night what's the most powerful piece
in black scam
yes okay but I think more importantly
the dark square Bishop is holding things
together
mmm-hmm 95 exactly simple as that
simple chess you're threatening the pawn
on e6 you're threatening the pawn on g6
and if you play Bishop takes e5 which
it's kind of forced it's just going to
be strategical capitulation yeah yeah
yeah ruk d6 is coming after that all the
dark squares in your camp are no longer
protected so just illogical chess
Bishop takes e5 actually let's try to
solve for this as well for Quincy eight
which would have been a different way of
trying to defend the position try the
calculator idiot it's not that difficult
nope
you shouldn't you shouldn't be thinking
about that move you should be thinking
about a completely different move and
try to calculate that till the end
90 X g6 Bishop takes g6 Cohen takes g6
Bishop takes c5 Queen takes h6 King g8
what I'm going to take your knife on c5
so night X g6 Bishop takes to g6 quaint
X g6 Bishop takes e5 because your night
is no longer protected Queen takes h6
check King g8 I am running away for my
life I'm offering your draw Queen g6
Queen h6 you want a drop
you're probably going to say no and then
you're going to play what
no that would be that would be a bad
move both Knights are missing yeah you
actually only have the bishop on b1
anymore and he has the knight on f6 and
the Bishop on c5 he doesn't have a
light-square bishop anymore
let's put it
but then I go back 90s on f6
not sure that that might win as well
that might win I mean I'm pretty sure
that should win nevertheless come on
guys simple simple just simple just
double attack very basic very basic
stuff so he didn't play Quincy it he
took on c5 but this is just game over a
rock to g8 everything is still protected
somehow continue attacking stuff now you
see the bishop on e8 is a completely
useful useless piece the knight on e5 is
just dominating that Bishop on EA the
knight on e5 is dominating the whole
position basically continue attacking
continue making normal moves
you should treat the bishop um be one
was no longer doing anything necessary
now it's time to shift on the other
diagonal yeah
always always always attack the
weaknesses King to g7 I mean you can do
a lot of things you can play Knight d5
then I take I take you cannot take back
and now we're left with the huge knight
on e5 against the bishop on the 8th
which doesn't do anything and with a
complete domination over the dark
squares I'm going to play room d6 Queen
d4 and the game is just going to be over
in no time
roof d6 yeah I mean there's so many I'm
just going to put my pieces on the dark
squares and then your king is going to
be getting checkmated very very quickly
so you play King g7 Bishop e6 broke a
fate and now the final blow
and it in style you probably have a lot
of wins in this position but one of them
just forces resignation basically maybe
but Rock this ever night night xd7
I think that should win as well I think
much easier was what he played 97 same
idea same idea the that's the problem
with with with group this 7 I think I'm
going to go night XD 7 I think it's
forced if you go Bishop d7 I go Queen d7
and that was the whole idea
and now King h8 Queen takes f8 and
you're going to get checkmated actually
King h8 Knight x26 checkmate in one move
so if you take back with the night now
that's the problem because Queen e7 King
h8 at least my knight protects the rukon
of faith I'm pretty sure it should still
be winning I think just Knight xd7
should finish the game yeah yeah Knight
xt7 finishes the game for sure
but I think just 97 first season it's
much easier much more force I guess
in this in this particular case it works
for the flashy for the flashy solution
of course but yeah 97 night x7 rook
takes d7 and then the game is over yeah
after 97 he resigned in anticipation of
this one so you see one thing that
chronic did didn't do is lose moves he
didn't make a single move without a
specific plan behind it and almost every
move he attacked something almost every
move he worked towards maintaining his
his initiative and not allowing his
opponent to finish his development and
arrange his pieces on their optimal
scores so that Bishop on maneuver is
actually a very typical plan so if you
if you ever encountered this type of
structure remember it always switching
diagonals between between the a to GA
diagonal and the b1 h7 diagonal is a
very useful thing to do yeah yeah yeah
yeah all right that's it that's class
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]